[Applause]
[Applause]
guys
[Music]
i'm just would like to know
have they created a safety violation for
what
maybe explain help them understand help
yourself and understand your for
stopping traffic no no no this gentleman
had a very good
i believe your point was valid no i'm
just we're discussing the fact that
hauling flammable fluids yep
horses
pose a danger to the public on a road
[Music]
[Music]
has weight
in the court of
immediate justice
so so would it be worth your time
before making a final judgment call
to exercise
your opinion and your
duty
to
ask
people that are managing the horses
their level of expertise in a situation
that you present which i believe you
have a valid situation
your handling of horses the issue is
that all this whole road north of this
area is closed for any traffic any
vehicles
okay regular
motorized or unless you have consent to
access beyond the barricade and you do
not so we've already spoken our hires
and they've already told us that these
horses are now allowed past this area
okay we can't have any vehicles whether
it's horse drawn or immortal
what was their reason what was their
sound reasoning safety concern you can't
have two horses public safety public
safety if the crowd was dispersed and
they were escorted and weren't even near
this thing okay would there be a safety
concern who's going to discriminate this
gentleman had a very good ballot oh
sorry
we're all together
you're that's fine you're all together
but we're also dealing with pros down
there
right what do you want to do there's
your safety concern for your crowd
this guy's very reasonable
where do you want to go with yourself
so sir sir
what other groups have been doing in the
past yeah they're actually putting their
hand carrying the fuel i understand
that's a hard ass okay but that's the
only thing we can permit right now is
that you take small little carts and you
can make your way
with pedestrians to carry the fuel to
where you want it to go so we can't get
closer to the vehicle
not with your horses
this gentleman is concerned about a real
a real a real situation
yeah okay so so when you are in an
uncertain situation you want to turn
into an expert these gentlemen are
expert in safety and protection
so i would ask them a question before i
would ask probably one of you guys
so are you
professionally expert do you think i
think you've managed this team of horses
if the situation
yeah we are we are we are so so if you
are willing to ask for perhaps maybe
some volunteers in the crowd
perhaps maybe to assist you so far to
keep all
obstructions or potential
obstructions out of harm's way
do you think your your higher-ups would
would would rest in that to get them
we've already been this is direction
we've already though this is direction
we've already received that's a public
safety issue but we're taking a wagon
regard regardless if it's filled with
wagon water food anything we're not
letting vehicles pass this checkpoint
okay we're not letting vehicles i got
you including horse-drawn vehicles past
this area that's it okay like i said if
you want you can unload the vehicle use
your other resources like your your
group to hand carry the material that's
fine
but the horse and buggy has to stay here
it's not going any further okay yes i
hear you okay now i have one final
question go ahead sir the man or the
woman the person making this decision
the person making the final decision
that gave you the command how close are
they to this this location it doesn't
matter they're receiving live updates
okay and they know they know the city
they know which areas are allowed and
which areas aren't allowed to have
traffic like vehicle traffic
okay so i went through a police line to
gain access to a hotel
with validation no with my car with
validation showing that i'm at that
hotel where a barricade is a block
whatever
so that was permissionable for me
upon showing validation and proof that i
was staying there
so if this honestly and i i understand
100 and perimeter control everything
we all support it
so if
if they could get that far
would that be a possibility
if it's what just to the next closer
already says we're not getting this area
zero zero
sorry sir all right
and to be honest like you don't have to
this is a situation we've never even
dealt with so we're trying to right well
you do have you to have police
[Applause]
[Music]
you